[Music]
so my childhood was quite hard
when i was five years old i fell in a
bath of boiling hot water
and i burnt the whole upper right hand
side of my body so it goes all up my arm
crossed my chest down onto my stomach i
had a jump around at the time
and i had little holes in it when i fell
into the water the water was so hot
that it melted my skin and my skin
melted over my jumper so my jumper was
on the inside of my body
at that point out of panic when my mum
came running up the stairs
she ripped my jumper off but when she
ripped my jumper off she ripped all my
skin off at the same time
i was in hospital for a long period of
time having various skin grafts from
removing the skin from my legs onto the
upper right hand side of my body
and when i came out of the hospital when
i started school
the young people couldn't understand why
i looked different they couldn't
understand
why i looked the way i did why my skin
was all funky and weird
and at that point they started to call
me names they started to bully me
basically said to myself you know what
i'm no longer gonna allow people to call
me names i'm no longer gonna allow
people to bully me
i was fighting to school in school from
school
i remember there was a time where i
completely blacked out and i just
smashed up the whole classroom
and there was also another time where i
blacked out and i punched out the whole
row of windows in my school just punched
just put my hand through water then
walked down the corridor
and i punched through all the windows in
my school so we got to a point where i
started to build a reputation for myself
i ended up having an episode where i
blacked out and i ended up picking up a
chair and i whacked my teacher with the
chair
and ended up breaking the teacher's leg
this resulted in me being kicked out of
the school
i was also banned from going to the area
as well
i remember being sat in the room with
the police my mom the teachers
and my mum was saying to them how how
much she
she couldn't control me and how much i
was growing out of control
the relationship with my mom wasn't good
i remember she took me to
social services she took me to the
office there and
she presented me to this lady and my mum
said to her
i need help with him either you take him
or i'm going to leave him here
she picked up the bag and she left the
building and she left me in there
but again all that stuff was fueling my
anger you know
it was fueling the person that i was
turning into
she kicked me out again when i was 13. i
was sleeping rough on the street
sleeping on the canal sleeping in the
bush sleeping under the bridge
trying to find anywhere that i could go
you know times i was sleeping in my
school uniform
going to school the next day and nobody
even knew
because i masked it i didn't want
anybody to know that i was living like
that that i was actually
suffering that i was in that position in
my head
the only place that i wanted to be the
only person i wanted to be around
was my mom even though we was going
through those hard times
she was still my mom the only place that
i really wanted to be was
at home in my own bed i ended up going
back home
but it was short-lived a week later my
mum kept me back out again
that was the most difficult period of my
life i don't think i've faced anything
more difficult than that period
i remember times i was going into the
job center i'm saying to them can you
give me money
i need money i need money they're
looking at me how old are you i'm like
i'm 15.
how come you're not in government care
how come you're not in a hostel how come
you're not
in a in a home and i'm like i don't know
the council have put me in this
emergency accommodation
it took the job center six weeks just to
decide what money to give me
because they told me that i was a unique
case took them another six weeks just to
actually give me the money
so throughout that whole time i was
without money i'm scavenging as i said
scavenging through bins i'm
i'm asking friends for a pound ah bro
you got a pound
are you on a pound four here's ah just
need to catch the boss bro catch the
boss
but actually in fact i used to buy you
know the custard cream biscuits
i used to stack them up on my side you
know i used to do i never used to eat
them
i used to crack them open lick them
stick them back together
and then put it back in the packet
because for me it wasn't the thought of
it wasn't a thought i've eaten it was
the thought of knowing that i had
food to eat so if it ever got to a point
where
i was really hungry i knew i had a pack
of biscuits that i could go to
but when i was at college that's when
things started to go
downhill started spiraling out of
control again
that's when i started to hang around
with a certain group of people
with the wrong crowd they could see that
i had this attitude they could see that
i had this
anger problem that i couldn't control
now these guys are in my flat
chilling eating that my food out of my
cupboard in my fridge
but now i start to hang out with them
even more so
we're in the town centre we're walking
around all the time
we're getting up to mischief causing
trouble and eventually that's how i
slowly slipped into gang culture you
know
there was two main gangs in birmingham
you had burger bar crew and johnson's
crew
now these two gangs at that time were
probably two of the biggest gangs in the
uk
two of the most violent gangs in the uk
so the guys that i knew maybe their
family was quite high up or
their individuals in their family were
quite high up and those were some of the
people that i used to hang around with i
used to that i used to roll with
and it was something that i clinged to
because i never had it anywhere else i
never had it from family members or
anybody else so
i knew that these are the guys that are
here for me you know
i was just a foot soldier you know i was
a foot soldier i wasn't nowhere
up in the ranking but again i was always
putting myself in those situations i was
always putting myself in danger
led me down the path of having guns and
selling drugs
and doing crime i remember the first
time i saw someone get stabbed and it
was like
didn't even phase me didn't even didn't
even phase me
at no point did i stand there and think
i'm gonna call the police or
i need to help this guy and i remember
it was a guy i was with he was a friend
at the time
and he was fight he was fighting this
guy and then all of a sudden like i saw
it first and i saw that actually he had
a knife and he was stabbing the guy
and i dragged him got him dragged him
and he stood up
and then that guy stood up the guy that
he was stabbing stood up
and he stood up and he was beating his
chest and he was like you're not going
to kill me you're not going to kill me
and one of his friends came put him in
the car and they drove away and i was
stood there like
did that just happen and again it kind
of made me think like oh like stabbing
people is normal like stabbing
stabbing someone they're not going to
die in it like you can i've just watched
my mess stabbing about 15 times
yeah it did i knew right from wrong i
knew what things
or the things that i was doing were was
bad i knew that
but i never had no one there to
to to say to me you know what has run
don't do that bro like
just calm down or come let me take you
somewhere else and let's do something
different
and i'll be honest with you even though
i knew that i was doing wrong
i didn't care i saw it as nobody cared
about me
so why should i care about you that's
how i seen it
and that fueled a lot of the rage inside
me when it came to the things that i did
all the little marks on my fingers there
including that one that one there's
actually teeth marks
there's been nights i've been sat in my
house and i'm taking man's teeth out and
my hands with a pair of tweezers
my whole knuckle there is split down the
middle that's why it's so big
split down the middle doctors have told
me that i'm going to have severe
arthritis in a few years
i'm starting to feel the effects of it
now i had this scar here on my head i
had a piece of glass that big sticking
out of my forehead
that i got a sky that runs across the
top of my lip i had a fight with five
guys
and a guy came with a metal bat and hit
me in my mouth
my teeth went through my lips so my lips
was inside my mouth and my teeth
protruding from my lips
that was all when i was what 16 17 18
all because i thought i was a bad man so
how bad did things get
i'm looking to 10 years in prison for a
rubbery charge
my own friends were sat in the dark at
crown court testifying against me
telling the court i don't know him never
met him before
never seen him before and these were
guys that i was chilling with
hanging out with i was the only one that
was found guilty
because the evidence stacked up against
me and i remember
i went for my pre-sentencing report at
probation
and i met this black woman i remember
man first
i literally stepped through the door as
i stepped through the door
this woman looked at me and she just
went not another black man that was the
first thing she said to me when i
stepped for the door
i'm thinking who is this woman it's nine
o'clock in the morning i'm thinking who
is this woman
number one and number two who is she
talking to you like that like what's
going on
and she looks at me and she says tell me
what happened tell me what you did
i looked at her and i said nah i ain't
no snitch i ain't telling you what i did
she's like snitch she's like little man
let me tell you something
you can't even be a snitch your friends
have already snitched on you anyway
you're the one that's been found guilty
you're the one looking at prison time
and i'm the person that can help you
and i sat there and i told her what i
did told her my involvement
told her about my upbringing my
lifestyle
and she looked at me she was like if you
go to prison your life's gonna spiral
out of control even more
i left that place thinking this woman
was chatting rubbish i was thinking i
don't know what this woman's talking
about
i'm going to prison that's what i'm
still thinking in my head
i end up going to my sentencing
and in my heart my heart's beating
constant i'm thinking i'm going prison
for
10 years but don't get twisted on the
outside i was cool
calm collected sat there like normal the
judge comes in
mr brown stand up i stand up
and when i stand up she looks at me and
she goes
i was gonna sentence you to prison today
i don't know what you did or who you
spoke to
but your pre-sentencing report was
glowing
and when she said that all that i could
think about
was the woman at probation all i could
think about was
what that woman had said to me when she
was saying hez run
leave it with me
you know when you just think about your
life and it just comes back
and you just realize that all the things
that you've been through in life
has brought you to the place that you
are now
sorry let me do that again
so what happened next so instead the
judge gave me a
two-year suspended sentence 280 hours of
community service
and a hefty fine and a couple days there
i was sat
in my flat with a friend of mine
and i just looked at him and i had this
epiphany and i said you know why are we
actually doing this
and he looked at me and he said we're
repping the end's heads repping the
postcode in it
he looked to me said hezron you're not
gonna change i said what he said you're
not gonna change you're not gonna change
from being the person that you are
i looked at him and i said yeah man
didn't have that faith in me
like i had the faith but i didn't need
him to have faith in me because
i knew what steps i wanted to take
i tried to get a job little success
reason why is because i never had no
skills i ended up volunteering
um for the british heart foundation
volunteered with them for a while
i went then and started doing courses
i've done things like customer service
skills
employability i done health and safety
i've done first
aid i've done my it i've done a pair i
don't i tip to level three
i've done a parenting course i don't
know why i'm doing a parenting course i
ain't got no kids
i then got involved with the princess
trust and i've done a get started with
theater program
the prince's trust got wind of it and
they were like ah
who is this guy that's gone from being a
thug gone from being a gangster
to now being an actor at the birmingham
rep theater like who is he
i ended up having a meeting with the
prince's trust and i became an
ambassador for them
going around the country telling people
about my lived experience
about my journey i remember the first
time i did it
i had the whole year group come up to me
at the front
and was just high-fiving me giving me
firms saying yo sir i can relate to you
sir i'm i'm currently going through the
same thing can you help me
can you offer me advice and i started to
think to myself like wow
when i was saying that the young people
are the ones that need to hear my story
it was true and then last year
i got a phone call by the prince's trust
and they were like hezrano do you mind
coming down to scotland i was like oh
yeah like what forward we're like oh we
want you to tell your story we're gonna
film it
we went around with a film crew and they
were filming me
telling my story around this beautiful
mansion
and we got into a room i sat down and
one of the cameramen looked at me and
said
oh i think he should stand up i said why
he went oh
just trust me stand up and as i stood up
prince charles walked through the door
and when he walked through the door i
was taken back
and i just couldn't stop crying man i
was balling balling again
i said i thought i was here to tell my
story
he said no no he said the reason why you
are here is because you've won the pride
of britain award
that same person that was looking at 10
years in prison
was now standing there next to prince
charles
with him telling me that i was the pride
of britain
it was an amazing moment it was an
amazing moment
what do you see as being a real turning
point for you
when i went to probation when i went for
my pre-sensing report
the woman that i met she could relate to
what i was going through
and she knew that by sending me to
prison
that was going to make me worse rather
than make things better
i don't know how she was so sure but she
was
so all i've got to do is just be
thankful
i mean listen till this day i've been
trying to find this woman
just so i can say to her look look at
what i've become
that day when you see me
if you would have just made a different
decision on that day
if you would have looked at me and for
actually you know what you deserve to go
to prison
i probably wouldn't be sitting here now
obviously i speak to a lot of councils
now
and when they hear my story and what
i've been through
they say to me oh he's run you was just
one of those people that slipped through
the net
well then even now i think to myself how
many people have slipped through the net
how many young people are out there
right now in an emergency accommodation
with no support no guidance no one
around them
yeah and i think that again that's why i
do what i do now to try and offer that
support to them
to try and mentor people that are in
those positions because for those ones
that have slipped through the net
at least someone is there to offer that
support people will always be quick to
tell you
nah you're not going to achieve that nah
nah nah you're not going to amount to
that
that's not going to work for you it's
not about where you are
it's about where you're heading and as
long as you keep that within your
brain you'll always win
you'll always win you'll always win
ten chinese authorities came home the
really big and fat guys
came to my home and they arrest me
in front my five years old child
my heart is just disappeared with and i
know that is
if i arrested and sent back to north
korea
i just execute or prison camp